you have just been targeted by lay Oreos
an inability judgmental pointing and the
only way to count this is to subscribe
to the New World review for regular and
glorious Hunter hunter updates funneled
straight into your YouTube feed then and
only then will they or your ceased to
judge you hello and welcome to the new
world review your source for everything
anime and manga and today it's time for
some more wonderfully subjective content
as while ago I decided to name my top 5
favorite characters in Hunter hunter and
now for the sake of glorious balance I
feel like it's important the week's port
the other side of that coin by examining
my least-favorite now I will say from
the outset that this list was nowhere
near as easy to make as I thought it
might be as it turns out there aren't
really many characters in Hunter hunter
that I don't like even some of the minor
and weird ones I think most of them just
get flushed out and presented in such a
brilliant and empathetic way that they
become quite difficult to dislike at
least for me so much so that if I were
to make this a top 10 list then I'd
probably have a difficult time filling
it but 5 sounds you know reasonable and
just to give you a bit of an idea of the
criteria for this list these are going
to be my least favorite characters
scaled in regards to their importance
and presence in the series so for
example if there's a major character
that I don't really like in a minor
character I don't really like then the
major character is going to get that
spot on this list because I was made to
spend more time with them in the series
so I would really have to properly hate
a minor character for them to appear
here today so let's not get shocked if
you know some from them figures pop up
because well it's going to happen and
let's also remember that these opinions
are entirely my own and not a personal
insult to you if you like who I happen
to dislike that's just the wonders of
being human plus I'd also like you to
keep in mind that just because a
character happens to be one of my least
favorite does not necessarily mean that
I hate them if I do feel that strongly
then I'll make shortly you know but
really most characters on this list
going to be here through simple dislike
or even apathy and finally all
characters on this list must be Canon
because if not and it would probably be
full of the non-canon Hunter hunter
verse but with that out of the way let's
begin welcome to my top 5 least favorite
characters in honde Hunter number 5
Jing freaks alright I can hear you Ola
ripping your dicks off from here but
just hear me out I accept the Jing kind
of is hunter hunter as without him there
would be no gone there would be minimal
kite and there would be no call to
action for us to spend the large
majority of the series working towards
and for much of Hunter hunter rather
understandably we have been striving to
find this man and when we did finally
get to him well to be completely honest
he was a bit of a disappointment to me
to state this right now I don't
necessarily dislike Jing not at all in
fact I find his part in the election arc
as well as the current Dark Continent
business to be endlessly fascinating I
love how his mind works in rivalry with
Paris tones but when I take a step back
from those wonderful scenes I take a
look with what I'm left with and at the
moment it isn't much we effectively have
a deadbeat dad who dresses like slob and
lives only to fulfill his own personal
desires and yes he probably does have
some pretty amazing and abilities which
will more than likely make him a
phenomenal character to look back on but
at this moment in the story we don't
have any of that although I guess to
jinx credit he was something of a mentor
figure to razor in fact you know I'd say
Jing was more of a father to razor than
he ever was to gone and that's what
really sells me in regards to putting
Jing on this list which is his attitude
towards gone the best thing Jing has
ever done for Gaughan was send him on a
convoluted mission to find his own
father with potential death waiting for
him at every single stage and if gone
did die well then Jing wouldn't have
been fazed at all
as shown by the fact that he didn't even
visit GaN in hospital after the Chimera
ant arc which to be fair once again did
lead to my favorite part about jinx
character which is when he was punched
in the face by Lee Oreo so I don't know
as much as I'm intrigued by jinx mental
battle with parastone and his mission to
go to the Dark Continent I can't help
but have this sense of something of a
dislike towards this guy and I know he
just isn't a great human being he's
charismatic sort of at least to the
readers anyway out of the actual
residents of the hunt underworld seem to
dislike him and unfortunately I tend to
land on the apathetic side so sorry Jing
but number four g2 so I think it's fair
to say that the chimera ants had some
really not-so-great characters but at
the same time I don't think any of them
managed to get on my nerves in the way
that she did and I guess I should say
once again that I don't hate cheeto at
all in fact I really enjoy what his
character represents which is an example
of how to completely misuse nen and
create abilities that don't work with
your desires at all and as such
always quite funny when she to was
foiled effectively by himself but he was
a very major player in a very long arc
and sometimes I just didn't want to be
watching or reading about g2 I suppose
if anything what g2 serves to do in the
series other than via [ __ ]
is to make everyone else around him look
good like I'm convinced that I only love
Morel as much as I do
because he made an even bigger fool of
cheeto whilst trapped in the Chimera ant
stack katsu and I guess another thing
about g2 is that unlike the other
squadron leaders I was never really
afraid of him in any way because he
always seemed to be a source of comic
relief which is crazy because cheetah
was pretty insanely powerful in the
grand scheme of things but he became a
bit of a weird existence to me as a
result and you know when he was
summarily dismissed by Silva Zeltiq my
response was ah I had no strong feeling
one way or the other
it was just g2 here one second and then
gone another oh well that just means we
now have time to focus on other
characters that was my thinking anyway
so look g2 I think this is where you
belong number three
Shia poof yet another chimera ant
gracing this list and I really have to
say the proof only appears above Chi 2
due to his significantly greater
relevance in the story boof is another
character that I am very apathetic
towards I find him to be by far the
least interesting of the Royal Guard in
almost every respect for example I was
never a fan of his design his overly
emotive nature and his use of Nan just
didn't really capture me in the same way
that you P or P toe did in all of those
areas
I do greatly appreciate his role in the
story and the fact that he was used to
explore the idea of questioning and even
betraying the king o for the twisted
sake of ultimately protecting him and
that element was very very necessary in
making the central stages of the chimera
and talk interesting and full of drama
but I guess I just didn't really care
for the vehicle that delivered so drama
in many ways proof also might be a
victim of juxtaposition I mean when you
constantly side by side with marrow MP
toe and you pee he will always seem
outclassed as a character to me like
whoever he was with was always the more
interesting individual to be focusing on
and you know on a certain level I'm sure
that we were meant to dislike proof as
well given that he spent most of his
time plotting against Kaimuki a
character who was so absurdly adorable
and slowly converting marijuana into a
more human way of thinking so naturally
when we as an audience see something
good happening and a character
desperately trying to prevent that good
and it's going to lead to a fair amount
of dislike at least I guess it did in my
case anyway number 2
Tompa so speaking of characters who were
designed to be disliked this is
certainly one of them as with all
characters on this list I do appreciate
what Tompa represents which was a bit of
comedy amongst a very theoretically
serious situation that was the hunter
exam however he was doomed to me from
the start because I'll be honest I just
hate everything about his design and I
don't think I ever got over that and
once again that was probably the point
Takashi created this overweight ugly
weird nosed bro who tried to give
everyone the shits in order to purposely
give the audience the [ __ ] and I don't
mind that to an extent but I think what
soured me on this guy was during the
third phase of the exam when he was
teamed up with our four protagonists and
just continues to be a dick beyond
belief at that point I understood the
character but I was just over him I knew
that he was an aesthetically unappealing
unredeemable minor antagonist who would
never amount to any real story impact
and so I just wanted to move on from
Tompa he simply could not provide us
with anything but an obstacle to get to
some actual substance in the series
still to be perfectly honest they do
kind of prefer Tompa to number one again
through so I swear in a series of almost
exclusively fantastic main villains this
guy is a bit of a stain on hunter hunter
and maybe that's a bit harsh but gained
through really does have some tough
contemporaries to stand up to and did
the company of people like Hisoka
illumise ride Nick Mero Emmett cetera
this guy just doesn't cut it
I mean gained through Falls very flat in
terms of basic motivation which is
killing for the sake of I guess killing
he likes committing acts of terrorism so
he does it cool sure but to me it just
lacks that extra layer of something
something like Sir riding and killing
for the sake of art and even then he has
particular targets or Hisoka engaging in
battle for sexual satisfaction once
again with specific targets but gained
through just does gain through things
because he's gained through he also has
by far the most forgettable design of
any major antagonist in the story so
much so that I quite legitimately do
often forget that he exists when
thinking of the villains of this world
and I should say that this has nothing
whatsoever to do with the final fight of
Gaughan versus gained through I love
that conflict but that love has nothing
to do with gain through it's more about
being a massive fan of exactly how gone
handled himself and unintentional there
and how he eventually overcame cancer it
really is one of guns crowning moments
in the series and gained through who
just happened to be there for
and I don't know I think I just expect a
hell of a lot more from a villain that
is being charged with helming and out
spanning 65 manga chapters and 16 to 21
anime episodes depending on if you watch
the 2011 version or the nineteen nine
anime OVA is respectively in defensive
gained through the greed island was also
a bit of a tricky Ock because it focuses
a lot on training and it's sandwiched
between york new city and the chimera
ants which is really not where you want
to be in this series because those arcs
are boats are profoundly memorable
pieces of story still an inner gain
through is just wholly underwhelming to
me I appreciate that he made go and look
good but I think he single-handedly
makes great Island a less than exciting
experience to reread or rewatch he was a
very stock standard villain during a
time when we needed to follow the
Phantom troop and gain through just
doesn't cut it which is one of many
reasons why he finds himself at the top
of this list here today and that pretty
much does it for my top 5 least favorite
characters in Hunter hunter if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general then please
do consider donating to the New World
few patreon because the support of all
of your amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and a
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video like share or
subscribe because it also help support
this channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my desk or
server where a wide array of shenanigan
tree takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your own
least favorite characters in the series
this has been the New World review and
they'll see you next time
[Music]
do you think that toga she might kill
off karateka at some point I absolutely
do
in fact togarashi has even stated in an
interview that the eventual fate of both
Cara pika and the Phantom troupe is that
they will all die now admittedly this
could be a comical response that gets
lost in translation but I also think
that everything we've been given
regarding Tropico points to his eventual
death which is actually explored in
another one of my videos entitled the
end of grafica a link to which will be
in the description below if you're
interested can you give us a brief
history of what you were thinking
you were going to become when you grow
up interesting use of tents they're
implying that I haven't grown up already
then again to be fair look I make enemy
videos on the Internet's Who am I
kidding
I have not grown up yet so when I was a
technical child though the first thing I
remember wanting to be was a cartoonist
and we're talking very young like the
ages of 5 to 7 the issue is that I
didn't particularly enjoy drawing at
this age and that was more something I
discovered I liked in high school so
pursuing the cartoonist route for me
never really took off and then I spent a
great period of my life not knowing a
single thing about what I wanted to do
until I saw my first commercial musical
when I was about 16 and they went huh
that looks like fun I want to work in
theater so based on that vague desire I
eventually went to university to study
design for TV in theater graduated and
began working as a lighting designer
technician and on the odd occasion even
a stage manager and eventually I even
did a musical in the very same theatre
where I first thought that this career
path would be a fun thing to pursue
which was a great well-rounded
experience in the last few years I've
been pretty disenfranchised by theater
though and so I've invested more time
into other hobbies one of which is this
whole YouTube thing and that's now very
much taking up a huge chunk of my time
so there you go that's a brief ha story
of the primary things I've wanted to be
and what I've ended up as currently